Ricky, oh my gosh
Your talk show was the biggest deal.
It was so epic, 11 seasons.
Yes, 11 seasons with my first show
and one season with my second show.
And one Emmy at the end of the day (laughs).
Yeah, boom, drop that mic Emmy thing.
I just had to throw that in there a little shameless plug.
Okay (chuckles) okay.
You had some episode titles that were totally iconic
and amazing and really wild.
And I was wondering if you remember any of them?
And if we could play a little game
that we're calling Is this Ricky Lake or Fake
based on your show titles.
(upbeat music)
All right, bring it.
(audience claps)
Okay, here's how to work.
I'll read you a title and you tell us
if it's an actual episode title
from Ricky Lake or it's a fake.
Okay.
Okay, here we go.
First title, "I'm in love with my cousin."
Ricky Lake or fake?
It's fake.
The answer is no
it's real.
Oh, it's really
to do with my show, oh.
Okay, next title.
"Your promiscuous cat got my cat pregnant
and you're paying kitten support or else."
Ricky Lake or fake?
I mean, it's derived from maybe one of my shows
but it is not a real title.
That is fake.
The answer is it's fake.
(audience cheers)
Okay, next title.
"I'm a real life vampire, today I'll prove it."
Ricky Lake or fake?
I'm going to say that's real.
It's real it's Ricky Lake!
Okay!
(audience cheers)
I don't remember that one, but okay.
Okay, "Whack 'em hard, smack 'em down,
mom, you can't stop them from the backyard wrestling."
Ricky Lake or fake?
I think that's actually a real title.
I think that's my show.
It's Ricky Lake!
(audience cheers)
I knew it, I knew it.
Okay, I'm getting warmed up now.
Okay, "Dad, I'm in love with a sweet potato pie
and you can't stop me from marrying it!"
Ricky Lake or fake?
That's fake, that's fake.
Yeah, it's a fake.
(audience cheers)
Okay, next title.
"Brother/sister you think I look like a circus freak,
but chill out 'cause you're a major geek."
Ricky Lake or fake?
I think that's my show.
It's a Ricky Lake!
(audience cheers)
(Drew laughs)
Okay.
Wicked first hours of television,
but that definitely rings a bell.
Oh good, okay fun.
Okay, "Your eyebrows are fake and everyone knows it!"
That's fake.
(audience laughs)
It's a fake!
(audience cheers)
Okay, "Stop dressing like a teen,
you're embarrassing me, Pastor Tom."
Oh, God, Pastor Tom.
I'm going to say that's fake.
Yes, it's a fake!
(audience cheers)
"How dare you write my number on the bathroom wall today,
you will pay."
Ricky Lake or fake?
I think it's fake.
It's a Ricky Lake!
(audience claps)
By the way that I feel like is a lost art
the writing the bathroom wall situation.
I don't know if it's a good thing to bring back or not.
Okay, "If you don't stop giving our baby
tattoos and piercings, I'm leaving you."
Ricky Lake or fake?
Fake.
Yeah, it's a fake.
(audience cheers)
Yeah, "You have naked pictures of me
and I want them back now."
Ricky Lake or fake?
Okay the last,
I don't think is that a Ricky Lake show title
but that was like my favorite show title of them all.
It's a Ricky Lake!
I love that one.
(audience cheers)
Yes, thank you so much for coming on the show.
Thank you Drew.
It's such a pleasure talking to you today.
Thank you for having me.
Thank you so much.
(audience claps)
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪